the whole working your life away just to
have a little bit of money a little bit
of free time to do things that you
actually enjoy it's such a waste of life
it's all nothing but a capitalist
hellscape that sucks the life out of
everyone
gets a few things wrong here just a few
starting most importantly with the very
common misconception that that happiness
means having a lot of free time to do
what you want you can't always get what
you want if that was true then virtually
no one who ever lived on earth up until
the Industrial Age at least was happy
because free time as she conceives it is
an extremely modern phenomenon